BOMBS.
IT RUNS OVER RAIL TRACKS.
IT'S SORT OF A CHOKE POINT IN
AND OUT OF THE CITY AND IT IS
LITERALLY RIGHT NEXT TO THE
AIRPORT AS WELL.
SO WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
BUILDING HIT HERE WAS SOME KIND
OF AIRCRAFT REPAIR FACTORY.
IT'S NOTE CLEAR IF THAT WAS THE
INTENDED TARGET OR SOMETHING
ELSE.
IT FITS WITH THE PATTERN
ESPECIALLY GIVEN WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN OTHER CITIES.
SE
TARGETS STAY AT OR AROUND THE
AIRPORT, PERHAPS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WILL GAMBLE THAT LIFE IN THE
REST OF THE CITY WILL BE
RELATIVELY SAFE, MAX.
>> WE'RE LOOKING AT THE IMAGES
FROM THE AIRPORT AND THE SMOKE
BUBBLING UP FROM THERE.
THE ASSUMPTION MANY ANALYSTS ARE
MAKING HERE IS THESE ARE ATTACKS
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
WESTERN COUNTRIES HAVE USED TO
SUPPLY UKRAINIAN MILITARY AS
OPPOSED TO A WIDER ATTACK ON
LVIV RIGHT NOW.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Reporter: YEAH, I MEAN,
THAT'S SOMETHING THE RUSSIANS
HAVE SAID BEFORE, SOMETHING THAT
THEY'VE SAID THAT FOREIGN
WEAPONS COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
WOULD BE FAIR TARGETS.
FOREIGN SOLDIERS, MERCENARIES
THEY CALLED THEM WOULD BE FAIR
TARGETS.
IN FACT, THE RUSSIANS WHEN THEY
HIT THE MILITARY BASE WEST OF
THE CITY OF LVIV, WHERE THE
RUSSIANS SAID THEY HAD HIT A
LARGE CACHE OF FOREIGN SUPPLIED
WEAPONS, SOMETHING THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE DENIED.
TO YOUR POINT, MAX, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THEY ARE
TRYING TO GO AFTER CERTAIN
WEAPONS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM AT LEAST AT
FIRST GLANCE THERE WERE LIKELY
ANY IN THAT AREA.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE WERE SIX
MISSILES FIRED, TWO SHOT DOWN BY
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS.
EVEN THERE IS A DANGER THERE.
FOR THE LAST TWO DAYS IN KYIV
WE'VE SEEN THE REMNANTS OF
MISSILES.
THERE'S AN AMBULANCE GOING
ACROSS THE BRIDGE THERE.
WE'VE SEEN THE REMNANTS OF THOSE
MISS STHIELS HAVE BEEN STRUCK
DOWN HITTING APARTMENT BUILDINGS
IN KYIV.